hi I'm markiplier and this is my wired
autocomplete interview I have googled
myself before I'm a bit egotistical like
that so I want to see what's going on in
the world about me
okay what is markiplier x' real name
mark edward Fischbach that is my name
what is markiplier x' catchphrase I
don't know I'm not a Pokemon I don't
have a catchphrase I say I say that a
lot that might be my catchphrase you can
bleep stuff out right
what is markiplier favorite game okay
confession I'm a bit of a fake gamer I
don't really play games on my own
casually anymore I like board games now
so those are pretty cool there's this
one I played the other day called
nemesis it's an amazing board game so
board games kind of my thing right now
what is markiplier favorite food this
one's easy
this one's chicken and dumplings from
Cracker Barrel there's nothing Quizon
airily qui cuisine le quiz there's
nothing amazing about the food itself
but there's something so comforting
about it my dad when I was growing up he
would cook biscuits in gravy you know a
lot of casseroles a lot of meatloaf a
lot of soups stews there's something
about Cracker Barrel chicken and
dumplings that just taste like home what
is markiplier is religion I am not
religious I don't consider myself to be
fully atheist but I don't go to church I
don't go to anything like that whenever
I was growing up we would go to church
every weekend and as I grew up I kind of
drifted away from it so I don't consider
myself to be religious what is
markiplier is net worth probably less
than what the estimates say but it's
more than I deserve way way more than I
deserve I live very comfortably and
that's something that I actually wrestle
with a lot because I don't spend a lot
of money on myself I like to eat cheap I
like to try to be as frugal as I
possibly can I donate a lot of my money
to charity I don't really care about my
net worth what is Mark flyers zodiac
sign it changed a few years ago didn't
it right didn't it check any one zodiac
in here I don't know the answer is I
don't know oh and I didn't mention
before but I wanted to mention a stylist
makeup artist the wonderful person I
don't normally look this good my hair is
a nightmare flyaways and everything so
this is not my day-to-day life but
like it hmm what does markiplier mean
that means nothing
you think this with thought up with any
like care like this is this is
multiplier with my name in front of it
what is markiplier like in real life
kind of a toll
I mean I'm nice people usually are
surprised when they meet me in real life
cuz I'm not screaming all the time and
I'm not allowed I like spending personal
time with people you know I like getting
to know people that's more personal to
me and that's more important to me what
music does markiplier listen to um I
used to not listen to music it wasn't
really a point but I just didn't have
time in my life to kind of seek out
music but my favorite band right now is
this band called here come the mummies
they are a funk band where there's 11 or
12 people in the band and they all wear
full mummy outfits they're so fun and
all their songs are about sex I don't
know it's just bizarre and I love them a
lot
what is markiplier x' real hair color
here here it is there it is what is
markiplier afraid of mannequins failure
probably a ubiquitous one Tripta phobia
i have tripped a phobia that's a fear of
like small holes like patterns of small
holes really creepy stuff what breed is
lucy markiplier oh my mom has a dog by
the name of Lucy Lucy is about the size
of a polar bear she's a great pyrenees
she's awesome
markiplier how to twerk ok there's
backstory to this some fan at some
convention asked me if I knew how to
twerk and I didn't but I tried then
following it up I decided to make a
video that was like one of my biggest
regrets on my channel there's so many
videos on my channel that are the reason
I can never go into a career in politics
and that is one of them why markiplier
ok this is probably the category that's
gonna expose me a lot why did markiplier
have surgery Oh before I did YouTube I
had a tumor in my
Newlands so my first surgery was to get
that removed the other surgery that I
had in the middle of me having a youtube
channel was I had scar tissue that had
adhered to my intestines so it blocked
up I became as doctors called it foolish
and I had to get that removed
why did markiplier drop out of college
well that whole YouTube thing I was
doing a lot of people questioned my
decision here because I dropped out when
I was two semesters away from graduating
I was a biomedical engineering student
and I had almost completed my degree but
I was doing YouTube and going to school
and finals for my senior project were
coming up like it was just one of those
things where I couldn't dedicate myself
to both so I wanted to dedicate myself
to YouTube full-time I wanted to take a
risk I worked as an engineering co-op I
didn't want to keep doing that I really
enjoyed this so that's why I dropped out
why was markiplier x' first channel
banned alright YouTube famously has a
lot of algorithms and a lot of systems
that are automated my first channel was
banned because they thought I was
abusing the Adsense system my channel
was not even monetized this is where it
was really heartwarming because I had
just under 2,000 subscribers back then
that was a huge number I basically put
out a video that was like look this is
the situation and if you guys can do me
a favor
Riis absque Ribe to this new channel and
they did 600 people followed that's when
I knew that I had something special that
people were going to be by my side that
was just a really important time in my
channel why can't markiplier drink
alcohol ok so I'm half Korean so a lot
of people in Korea they can't process
alcohol correctly they get red in the
face when they do I get that to a super
degree the last time that I really drank
alcohol I actually had a heart attack I
was in the bathroom and I felt dizzy it
didn't go away and then I I passed out
and I felt silly because they called
Manuel it sounds like no that's not
needed and then in the ambulance right
over I had
another heart attack it's a very weird
thing and I'm not risking that again to
drink so that is why I can't drink
why does Mark flyer have a pink mustache
this harkens back to the beginning of my
channel I did a sketch with this
character Wilfred Worf stache who was
supposed to be a news character I did
that people really love the sketch
people make fan art of it and so it's
become such an important part of my
channel that it's kind of become the
symbol why is markiplier king of five
nights at freddys because I said so why
is markiplier taking a break this was a
while ago
I basically been making two videos a day
every day without vacation up until this
point and it was getting to me that I
was making videos every day that I
wasn't really proud of it was getting to
me that I wasn't making videos that push
myself I wasn't using to learn anything
new I wasn't using to elevate myself and
it was just getting to me and so I
needed to step back and I needed to take
a month and when I came back from that
you know I came back with a better
mindset and I came back with a healthier
attitude about you know making videos
like I can push myself and I can do
these videos that people love and I can
find ways to be creative it's crazy that
I'm only answering these questions now
instead of explaining when I did it you
know it's only really hindsight that
lets me realize why I needed this so
badly
who markiplier who drew mark pliers icon
I should know this it was so long ago
they did a wonderful job of course they
did a good job but now I seem like such
a soul because I don't even know their
name that's the tragedy of it and that
that was like the first crisis of my
channel as I was getting so popular that
I wasn't able to keep up with everybody
there were times when the people that I
thought I knew you know I forgot them
completely and people would come out of
the woodwork like hey where are you all
you're too big now to hang out those
kinds of things they me up it's just
like I don't have enough time for
everybody I don't have enough time for
everybody there the first time that I
got an email from a parent of a kid who
passed away they watched my videos I was
broken inside like that that just tore
me up inside and knows his other
there was a southern make-a-wish kid
that I had met just on a whim like I
flew out to the seer and and then I
found out two months later that she'd
passed away I was always done for days
after that like I couldn't think
and I couldn't like I couldn't even
fathom that concept that someone who
would laughing and you know was a
wonderful person was gone I barely had
the chance to know her I mean it changed
everything it's why just like two weeks
ago I I was sitting down and I wanted to
do a 48 hour charity stream to raise
half a million dollars like I've never
done that before and I wanted to do it
and everyone was like 48 hours it's a
lot it's like compared to what people
have been through
that's nothing if I can and raise money
for for good and if I can dedicate
myself to these causes and if I can keep
trying to push my audience in the right
direction then like why wouldn't you do
that
why would you not do that I went way way
off topic I went way way off topic there
I'm sorry about that who edits
markiplier zuv videos ok so right now
this wonderful person by the name
Alexian he has been an animator
animating some of my videos my gameplay
stuff for years since the very beginning
he's been kind of the backbone of my
channel I just talked with him the other
day and I asked him if he wanted to go
full-time and he said yes hell yes Emily
that's so amazing because he's better at
editing the videos than I am who was
Martha Flyers first subscriber ah this
was my friend Michelle I sent out on
Facebook a long time ago they like hey I
got a YouTube channel anyone want to
subscribe and none of my friends did and
Michelle was my first subscriber and
Michelle believed in me and Michelle was
there for me so Michelle if you see this
you're awesome who is markiplier II is
that talking about the e meme I don't
know man
someone basically used that as a joke
not even a real meme and then I think
the irony because the internet thrives
on irony decided that that was the thing
that they were gonna grab on do for
months and I couldn't do a single live
stream ever again without my entire chat
just being nothing but e at this point I
have no license or desire of license of
this image which is why I keep it at a
very low level of upkeep like at this
point I'm just a walking nightmare so
who is Henry markiplier Henry is my
girlfriend's new dog who killed
markiplier explanation okay so I made
this four part series called who killed
markiplier that told the story of well
who killed me and it's a little
confusing because I left the ending
intentionally ambiguous a lot of people
were confused about it and there's a lot
of like mystery about it but I kind of
like that because it's a part of history
so maybe the answer isn't quite so black
away is markiplier good at fortnight
better than people think because I
played it casually on my own a lot but
talking and playing at the same time is
not a skill I'm particularly good at but
I'm average is markiplier going on tour
I was I don't want to go on tour again
for now because it is a drain on my life
and it is so hard to do and it is just
grueling it is nice to go out there and
meet fans but tour life is not the life
for me is markiplier in space no is
markiplier John wick no I don't know
whatever you want it's your fantasy is
markiplier liberal pretty liberal
yeah pretty mostly liberal liberal
liberal liberal is markiplier vegan
absolutely not I love meat I love eating
meat now that being said I've always
thought that like if they could lab grow
meat that was even close to as good as
meat meat I would eat that fine because
then you know there aren't any animals
being killed is markiplier done with
YouTube no no no a little bit no not at
all I am not done with YouTube it is
still a wonderful platform as much as
people should on YouTube
not be the best place to make a living
especially right away but it is a great
place to get your ideas and thoughts out
there boom that's what I do
thank you everybody that asks a question
thank you for googling these things I
bet you didn't expect that your Google's
were going to be pulled up but you know
the Internet is no longer private so
everybody is exposed to everybody now
seriously thank you guys so much for
being even remotely interested in my
boring life yeah thanks for watching and
thanks for the interview